we are taking calls at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50
we were gonna go to our caller from the
4:08 area code caller from 4:08
go ahead who's this hello
that's you hi I'm Ari I'm calling from
the Bay Area Ari are we on either
speakerphone or a Bluetooth headset yeah
okay if you could take us off it would
be we'd be able to much better hear you
but go ahead what's your question today
okay okay let me just do this here okay
can you hear me better that is so much
better thank you I appreciate that okay
yeah no problem I want to address I
think of one of the few areas like I
think me and you would probably disagree
regarding sort of our relations with
Iran and Russia
I was curious because I tend to agree
with sort of the the Stephen Cohen's
demur timers like the world Christians
and the Chomsky's about the yeah yeah
that when it comes to Iran and Russia
the the grievances our government has
against those regimes is not the ones
that are advertised you know and that
essentially that our main problem with
these regimes in the case of both the
reigns and the Russians that is that
they are sort of serving as sort of an
effective impediment against us being
able to pursue our interests
geopolitically or economically I mean in
the case of Iran I think even see I
think the main concern is that not that
the Iranians would use a nuke but that
if they were to acquire one it would
give them considerable leverage to be
able to undermine Saudi Arabia Israel
and the United States further I think
even a lot of Israeli officials who
really don't have a political incentive
to disagree with the Netanyahu sort of
concede the fact that the Iranian regime
is rational albeit odious really
although you know that the fact that
they're odious actors sure and real
quick in the case of Russia many would
surmise that many I mean many would make
the case that other countries like Saudi
Arabia as well as the Israel sort of in
their own ways sort of
undermining are involved in our
democracy and detrimental ways but Putin
it just so happens that our interest
sort of coincide with those countries
but in the case of Russia if you look at
you know as an example of Syria we're
obviously involved in some sort of proxy
war with them so it we sort of see as
Vladimir Putin I mean nobody's you know
justifying his behavior but he certainly
a lot of in our way a lot of people that
are hold on so so you there's a lot
there so let's see if we can bring it
down first of all a lot of people are
justifying Putin's behavior as even
logical if you are Putin right like we
totally understand why if you were Putin
you would behave in a particular way or
if you were Iran you would behave in a
particular way so I don't think you're
right to say no one's justifying their
behavior tons of people are but I want
to focus on a different part of what you
said first of all there is sometimes
things are not as they seem and
sometimes things are as they seem but
there's a movement on the left and it's
been around for for several decades that
fixates on this entire you're not going
to know the real truth unless I tell it
to you everything that you've heard up
until this point is not the real thing I
have for you the real motivation which
is lying just below the surface and
everybody else is lying to you about
what's actually going on like listen
things are complicated sometimes a
combination of things are going on
sometimes what appears to be going on
really is what's going on so I think
number one it's very important to have a
sort of healthy balance of skepticism of
institutions of power and authority and
those who have motivations to have you
believing one thing or another but also
not to fall for this sort of like
romanticized there's always a truth that
you're not going to get unless you hear
it from the right key people and it
doesn't matter who it is like it could
be Chomsky or Jess not Jesse Lee
Peterson Jordan Peters right there's a
lot of people that deal in this trade of
I'm going to tell you what's really
going on so what let's step away
from that a little bit now let me ask
you this let's assume that you're right
that there are other reasons than the
ones publicly stated for why the US has
a certain perspective on Iran or on
Russia if crimes were committed by the
Trump administration in receiving help
from Russia for the purposes of winning
the 2016 election should that be
investigated fully and adjudicated fully
regardless of what the hidden
geopolitical agenda is with Russia yeah
I would say so okay and and to be clear
I wasn't actually looking at it from the
lens of Trump Russia connection as much
as sort of the way we framed the Trump
our relationship with Russia you know
going back to you know sort of the late
Bush administration mm-hmm so I mean and
and and I'll say real quick I think that
the problem is there is a historical
there is there's a precedents for you
know the way we've been fooled with
regards to our government and you know
the way they framed our relations are
the threats from you know other
countries like you rocket you know
absolutely and so it it's hard to it's
very difficult for us if you sort of
coldly kind of accept that yeah we
should really think about military
action against Iran given this the
historical precedent in recent history I
don't know I agree I I don't disagree
with you there I just think it's it's
important not to fall as a result of
that for the the this the soothsayers
who will tell you what's really going on
in all cases really no fear at all re
very much appreciate it I do have to run
I've got I've got people who want to get
on